jambes at-il dit khabar you worry free
va-t-il amnistié sa famille son avocat
personnel et roddy julienne ils votent
ils lui-même ce taux graciée j'en ai
parlé avec anne deysine juriste et
spécialiste des questions politiques et
juridiques aux états unis 92e bonsoir
bienvenue à l'émission non soir le
procureur général ban contredit le
président trump il n'y a pas de fraude
qu'est-ce que ça envoie comme message
pour selon vous ce qui est intéressant
c'est de contraste et le discours qu'a
fait le président en 46 minutes criblé
de mensonges c'est à dire malgré tout
les déconvenues qui l'a chaque jour
depuis un mois et l'énorme déconvenue
que son ministre de la justice qui est à
un fidèle de chez les fidèles et qui
jusqu'ici est bien resté de ces derrière
le président mais là il a dit nous
n'avons trouvé aucune fraude peut-être
deux trois irrégularités mais aucune
fraude et surtout rien qui soit
susceptible de faire basculer l'élection
donc quelqu'un d'un tout petit peu
normal comprendrait que c'est fini mais
lui continue
alors est-ce qu'ils pourraient congédié
bacs d'ici le 20 janvier comme il le
fait avec son gant responsable de la
cybersécurité et de et des dernières
élections
oui c'est possible mais il a dit
d'ailleurs lorsqu'il a été interrogé
on verra redemander voix dans quelques
semaines comme s'ils étaient au pouvoir
pendant des semaines et des semaines
encore alors qu'il ne reste que cette
semaine il est possible qu'ils le moche
barre de toute façon il ne se passera
pas grand chose pareille se rappelle ce
qui s'est passé quand un il a limogé
comme est hélas tous ses proches
il suggère de ne pas se débarrasser du
ministre de la justice
peut-être bar va-t-il rester jusqu'au
bout on ne rapporte des discussions à la
maison blanche un but de
pardon préventif en fait allé présenter
des pardons en fait donné avant même que
les gens soient accusés pour son
entourage
est ce que vous y croyez est-ce que
c'est fondé en droit alors le pardon
c'est un pouvoir qui appartient au
président qui est un pouvoir très large
il y à une seule exception
il n'est pas possible de gracier
quelqu'un qui a été mise en accusation
in pitch ce qui pourrait poser problème
puisque à la différence du président
nixon le président prend pas lui était
mise en cause ici par l'accusation par
la chambre des représentants
alors concernant ses proches il ya
effectivement une jurisprudence de la
cour suprême qui laisse entendre qu'il
est possible de gracier de façon un peu
préventive
est ce que fait 30 c'est de s'assurer un
que ses enfants son gendre et sans doute
julia ni ne seront pas embêtés pour
eux-mêmes mais aussi parce que les
gracier veut dire qu'ils ne pourront pas
être inculpé et que par conséquent ils
ne risquent pas lui par contre coup
d'être inquiétées donc ils essaient de
se protéger mais faut être bien
conscient que ce droit de grâce de
s'applique qu'aux crimes et délits
fédéraux
c'est à dire ce qu'il a pu faire pendant
qu'il était à la présidence lancera dans
la justice etc
mais par exemple la fille de trump a été
entendu pour des malversations
concernant la fondation trump a priori
c'est plutôt le droit de l'état de new
york donc ça ne serait pas couvert par
cette grâce
de même tous les problèmes fiscaux les
problèmes de fraude bancaire et cetera
qui sont poursuivies à la fois par le
procureur de new york et par la ministre
de la justice de new york
tout ceci ne seraient pas effacées même
si trump décidé de ce glacier qui
pourrait y avoir une influence politique
venue de washington par exemple de
l'annonciation bahreïn qui se dirait on
n'a pas intérêt à poursuivre toutes les
équipes 30 ni la famille parce que ça
valait le rendre encore plus victimes ça
va lui mettre les feux de la rampe
on n'a pas intérêt politiquement elle
poursuit croyez-vous que par exemple
dans le district de dans l'état de new
york
on pourrait tenir compte de tels
facteurs ou pas alors c'est vrai que
bayonne a annoncé que
ne gracierait pas le président ce qui
serait possible techniquement
juridiquement il ne va pas le faire mais
il a indiqué aussi qu'il n'était pas
pour faire de l'acharnement
ce qui est d'ailleurs très difficile à
comprendre pour trame parce que si trump
était dans la situation inverse il ne
voudrait qu'une chose se vengeait
poursuivre etc mais by donne et c'est sa
politique de l'apaisement je ne suis pas
sûr que ça va marcher mais dans le cas
de cette politique d'unification du pays
il va certainement pas faire d'
acharnement au niveau fédéral est-ce
qu'il peut passer un petit coup de fil à
new york au responsable oui mais enfin
nous sommes dans un état fédéral comme
chez vous et il n'est pas certain que
cyrus vance le procureur de new york est
envie d'entendre maiden et puis quelque
part c'est quand même un petit peu
gênant de laisser tous ces crimes et
délits a puni parce que l'avantagé entre
guillemets de la présidence tram c'est
qu'on a pu constater que des crimes de
corruption des crimes de la criminalité
en col blanc en grand nombre n'était pas
sanctionné
on a bien vu tous les proches de trope
finalement ils n'ont pas été inculpés
pour des crimes d'état si j'ose dire
mais il avait violé la législation sur
lobbying de puissance étrangère ils
n'avaient pas déclaré leurs impôts ils
avaient mis de l'argent étranger donc il
ya toute cette criminalité en col blanc
et si ce que fait southbound peut
permettre non pas 2 rumble moraliser la
vie politique mais un petit peu ce
serait une bonne chose donc il n'est pas
certain que l'état de new york ce se
plie aux demandes du président mbaye
dème en même temps à pardonner sa
famille ou même giuliani c'est au fond
reconnaître de manière préventive même
leur propre culpabilité c'est reconnaît
qu'il aurait pu commettre des gestes
illégaux
cela dit s'il faute il s'auto pardonner
alors lui elle a déclaré plusieurs fois
je peux tout à fait mais oui moto
amnistié moto graciée alors c'est un
problème à plusieurs niveaux en terme
des typologies le mot pardonne en
anglais vient du pardon en français et
de données et donc a priori ça implique
de personnes celui qui donne et celui
qui reçoit donc s'auto amnistier ça
paraît bizarre mais surtout c'est
contraire à toute la tradition anglo
saxonne
et en particulier à ce qu'avaient voulu
faire les pères fondateurs lorsqu'ils
ont écrit la constitution et qu'ils ont
mis des points différents entre le
système anglais où le roi était source
du droit ce qui n'est pas le cas du
président des états unis et toute la
culture anglo saxonne dit bien que le
président n'est pas au-dessus de la loi
nash a obtenu la balise barbe d'or et là
s'il pouvait c'est à dire s'il était il
y aura certainement s'il devait faire ça
il y aurait des contestations devant des
juridictions suture élections devaient
valider cette auto amnistie quelque part
c'est une répudiation de ses traits que
personne et dessus du droit
je n'y crois pas je pense que 30 se
rendent compte que ce n'est pas très
efficace s'ils ne fait pas cela c'est
pas parce qu'il sera devenu intègre
morale c'est parce qu'il se rendra
compte que les coûts l'emportent sur les
bénéfices
c'est toujours ça son approche de chaque
problème en mai mais en ce moment ils
recueillent des fonds on dit qu'il
aurait déjà recueilli 170 millions de
dollars pour poursuivre les ses recours
alors que tu as fait parce qu'en fait
c'est la libye il dit à tous ses
supporters tous ses partisans et des
mois même 5 $ et des mois et des mois et
c'est d'ailleurs honteux que des gens
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent se prive
pour alimenter ce fonds mais quand on
regarde les petites lettres comme on dit
comme dans les contrats d'assurance
on constate que cet argent ne va à la
défense du président qu'au-delà d'une
certaine somme généralement ça mille
dollars et qu'en fait tout cet argent
et j'ai aussi le chiffre de 170 millions
de dollars c'est beaucoup en quelques
jours vont alimenter à un pack un comité
d'action politique pour la future
éventuelle carrière du président en
d'autres termes le président trucks qui
sera plus président pourra faire ce
qu'il veut avec ses 170 millions de
dollars
et c'est encore un scandale encore une
pollution supplémentaire d'une
corruption vraiment au sens de la loi ou
au sens figuré
les deux alors oui vous avez raison
parce que dans le sens purement légale
mais la corruption et que ce type de
mécanisme existe parce que c'est
mythe et d'action politique existe et
c'est à dire que on collecte d'argent en
faisant penser que ça sert à telle chose
alors qu'en fait ça va servir un tel
autre chose pour moi ça fait partie de
cette corruption un petit peu systémique
du système américain avec le financement
des élections l'argent et des choses qui
ne sont pas sanctionnés alors je ne suis
pas sûr qu'elle serait sanctionné même
s'y tromper poursuivi mais ce serait
peut-être pas mal un petit peu de faire
avancer certains dossiers de poursuites
la tienne des merci beaucoup merci à
vous et à bientôt
or